irgendwann die luft land der transport
über
70 jahre da geht es darum das
zusammenwirken aller erwähnte dass im
privat- und nach lufttransport zu
trainieren und dem ganzen zu grunde
gelegt ist ein szenario wo es in teilen
österreich zu einem kontrollverlust
gekommen ist es befinden sich dort
aufständische wir haben da zwei
rivalisierende gruppierungen und jetzt
geht es darum im wesentlichen aus dem
raum wiener neustadt hier am übungsplatz
in allenstein diese beiden gruppierungen
wieder zu separieren und diese ganze
situation unter kontrolle zu bringen mit
den deutschen kameraden die kommen von
der luftlandebrigade 1 eine langjährige
kooperation wir haben derzeit einen
stand von etwas über 1300 soldaten das
englische sprechen und funken das ist
dann folgen für die zweite woche dieser
nach der evaluierung das erfordernis